well what it is is when you have the
same base okay in an equation like this
you can set the exponents equal to one
another
so if a to the x equals e to the Y then
X must equal Y so a very simple example
would be if you had 10 to the x equals
10 squared the only way that this left
side could equal this right side given
that the bases are the same is that the
exponents also have to be the same so X
would equal 2 now that's a simple
example let's do a few more challenging
ones so let's take like a letter a here
3 to the x equals 81 so the first thing
we want to do is see if we can get these
bases to be the same so what you'll
recognize is that 81 is really 3 to the
fourth so we have 3 to the x equals 81
which is 3 to the fourth now we can see
that we have the same base we can set
the exponents equal x equals 4 let's
look at another example here we have 2
to the X minus 2 equals 1/16 now what
you want to recognize is that 1/16 is
actually 2 to the negative fourth power
okay why 2 to the negative fourth power
well 2 to the fourth is 2 times 2 times
2 times 2 4 times at 16 but the negative
exponent tells us to take the reciprocal
okay so now we have the same base we can
set the powers equal and you can see
that X minus 2 equals negative 4 add 2
to both sides and you can see x equals
negative 2 now if you want to check your
answer just go ahead and take that
negative 2 put it back in here and you
get 2 to the negative 4 which again
gives us 1/16 let's do another example
e to the x squared equals e to the 4th
this one's pretty much set up for us you
can see we have the same base now all we
have to do is set the powers or the
exponents equal take the square root of
both sides but don't forget when you
take the square root of both sides how
many answers do you get two answers plus
or minus two and then the last example
16 to the x equals 2 what you might
recognize here is that they both have a
2 in common okay base 2 16 to the X is
actually 2 to the fourth all raised to
the x equals 2 to the first if you don't
see the exponent that means this is a 1
and then now when you have a power to
power you multiply those exponents so
it's 2 to the 4x equals 2 to the first
now you can see that if we set the
exponents equal to each other for x
equals 1
divide both sides by four and you can
see that X is going to be 1/4 so this
concludes this video about how to work
with the one-to-one property with
exponents
subscribe to the channel check out more
math videos on Mario's math tutor and
YouTube channel and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon